it might look a little bit weird but I'm
gonna see if I could stretch it for you
guys
it won't be stretched for me but it'll
be stretch for you
laughs
[Music]
foreign
I know I just fixed it
[Music]
testing testing testing testing
work with me guys
[Music]
all right can you guys hear me fine
what's going on man
[Music]
everything looks good and sounds good
why is there a verbers
oh you're hearing my actual phone
keep listening babe make sure you can
hear it fine
make sure there's no Echo
[Music]
so I mean I could probably try to fix
that a little bit more
but it's gonna distort it the more the
more I fix it
[Music]
all right
all right so
[Music]
I ain't really supposed to be
there we go
you can actually hear me well I
appreciate that man
so I what I've done is I have cut all
the red the black borders out
uh you know hopefully things will work
the way it's supposed to
[Music]
now it might look a little bit weird
but I I think I think everyone should be
good I think everyone should be good
I got my handy dandy water right here
[Music]
greetings for mantra what's up man I
always really enjoy the fact that people
watch us from all around the country I
mean the world
always enjoy that
you guys have no idea how many times
I've beat this game it's a little
ridiculous
[Music]
I've beat this game quite a bit of times
I gotta get used to these new settings
on the switch controller
[Music]
if I remember crackle we need like 20 or
40.
oh
[Music]
let's go get the sword real quick
I should uh
I should pirate the stuff up man but you
know
I can't do that
[Music]
come on come on
I wonder if they'll let me get this
already yeah it will
[Music]
oh I love it man I I I don't do you do
you hear the um
the game playing twice
I hope you guys don't I can't really
help that right now currently
because what was going on here is I need
I need a pair of headphones
because like things just get weird
sometimes
all right
man this game brings a lot of memories
back
okay we got the sword
[Music]
we need some more money
what buttons like the free room
[Music]
all right so that's the
I guess we'll just random okay it sounds
fine all right
I remember there's a ruby between one of
these yeah
[Music]
hold up
we don't need a heart
let's run across
what's funny is with the N64 controller
this used to be very complicated because
like how bad the conditions of those
controllers was
[Music]
thank you
maybe cut the grass at spray's house
Miller told me it was pretty good
he would do it so she would like him
okay I get you fam I get you
we need more money
[Music]
you get to that but I'm gonna go get
this
[Music]
I think we only need seven more
what question man did you send me a
question on Facebook not a Facebook I
don't know why I said Facebook on a
on Twitter
send me a question on Twitter man
[Music]
there we go we got enough for a shield
now
it's crazy how much I remember this game
you never really forget this guy
no we're not facing you we're going
straight through
[Music]
even down to how much it costs 40 rubies
come on man no I don't want to buy
anything else
[Music]
I don't really got the money to buy
anything else to be honest with you
but we got what we need to go in this
next place
[Music]
see normally if you try to go through
here this dude will tell you you can't
go unless you have the stuff you need to
go in there now I do have it it's just I
had to get it first
[Music]
let me in
thank you
see this is like what breath of the wild
was missing me man it's just like these
moments
[Music]
breath of the wild you know it's it's a
good game it is but I I do think people
exaggerate just a little bit
I don't really care what he has to say
he's pretty much going to tell you the
uh
how long did it take me to finish wulong
it didn't take uh I think about 40 hours
it took me
I'm currently playing another game but
I'm not allowed to talk about it until
well I don't even know if I'm allowed to
tell you
I don't even know if I'm allowed to tell
you when it ends like when the Embargo
ends
hey guys post post this stream on
Twitter man
let people know I'm streaming
[Music]
I didn't mind the breaking weapons I
just mind the lack of temples like this
thing right here
this Temple right here is more of a
temple than all of breath of the wild
and I feel like that's an issue
uh maybe depends if I get a review code
most likely most likely because I doubt
I'll get a review code
but I'll try to get a review code but I
doubt I'll get one
[Music]
I don't know why my like
my
see if you kill him like this you get a
Deku nut but if you kill him straight up
you get a Deku uh
a Deku stick
ow
[Music]
this game still holds up I don't care
how do I use my shield
okay
all right so what we have to do here
is we have to break this
and the way to break that is we have to
climb these get to the top and jump off
we about to do that though
[Music]
uh okay we have to jump
I appreciate it man
see right now we have nothing to take
out these skeletons with so we just
can't trigger them the only way that you
trigger them is that they look at you
this is the dungeon we kind of need the
dungeon
foreign
oh
that's bull
[Music]
I'm still getting used to these controls
again
yeah I appreciate you sharing it out man
tell people pick up your boys streaming
you know I know I don't stream as much
and I don't always say I'm going to
start streaming
um but you know
life be happening I don't know what to
say
so you got to break that
which the last raid that we just did
the one with um
I don't even remember his name that's
how much I care about it
[Music]
yes I know I can open the door I wish
they'd let you skip the tutorials if you
already know what you're doing
all right
we gotta knock him back to him
gotta catch up to him don't let him get
in
will you let me go when you jump off a
high cliff if you go forward you will
roll on the ground when you land it
won't get hurt by damage
I can't guarantee what the cliff is
really high
I wish um
I wish they gave you the master quest I
was originally going to try to play the
Masters Quest because I've only viewed
it once
but it didn't work out so well
this is probably I don't think this is
the slingshot I think this is the
compass
[Music]
oh it is a slingshot
oh they expected you to go through there
first it's been so long since I played
this game that some things are
shooting by me but for the most part I
remember the majority of the uh the
temples I I don't remember the fire
temple as much as I
as much as I should
okay
that's gonna take some getting used to
so
hold up
[Music]
which one's which I wish they would
all right so I can't
it's the button to
wow this is crazy
which one's that
hold up
[Music]
is there a button for like the
okay yeah
all right so if I press the Z button
all right so that works out better
all right there we go
[Music]
but
is it yeah it is the switch version
after this we're probably gonna go to uh
majoro's Mass to be honest with you
I'm hoping I can beat this game today
like I don't know we'll see
you can get up there without killing
them
it's just hard because you can't see
entirely up there
one of the best Zelda games oh it
definitely is
foreign
you can't go any further than this I
think you do jump off this
let's go in here first though
all right so we have a fire puzzle here
[Music]
let's kill this dude first
there's one thing you could say about
the 90s versions of Zelda's like the the
boss the the creatures themselves wasn't
really that complicated because
seeds
[Music]
for some reason I'm wanting to say they
used to be called Deku nuts I don't know
why
[Music]
it's taking a little bit of time to get
used to um
[Music]
all right hold up hold up
there we go
[Music]
got that compass
we ain't really gonna have we ain't
gonna really need it too much
for the most part I remember the
majority of these samples there's a
couple that might be a little bit
like shady for me
but for the most part I remember these
turn around dude
he's got to turn around
there we go
all right now we jump off
[Music]
and it breaks
simple as that guys simple as that
this first 10 point really that
complicated
so I wanted to do the master quest
because this would be a lot harder with
the master quest
all right hold up
that's supposed to be spider web
felt like they could have made that look
a little bit better
[Music]
all right let's do this
I think this gives us a key
uh just a heart
[Music]
go
easy man
[Music]
say easy
one of the best Zelda games
so I think you have to beat them in a
certain order I can't remember the order
the order is two three one
[Music]
there we go
second
I remember this one there's uh something
special in the master quest for this
room
[Music]
because
hold up
[Music]
oh yeah it's right here
you got a certain amount of time to get
to it
[Music]
I might not make it because it's on
literally the other side
we'll see though
stand next to this block and grab it
hold of it hold a while
I just wish they would let you like Fast
read these like they make you read
individually
I don't think I'll have realistically
time to beat multiple Zelda games like
that but I would love to play Wind Waker
one wicker is such a fun zone again
but this week I should have Zelda B I'm
hoping I beat it today most likely it
won't be today
so someone look up on how to how long
does it take and tell me how long it
takes to beat Zelda Ocarina of Time what
I do not like none of the extra stuff
but I'm wondering how long it takes
[Music]
Ocarina sounds like real big on that
catching stuff on fire thing
[Music]
yeah you didn't think I was gonna do
that did you buddy
[Music]
oh yeah these things
ah
someone texted me let me oh Advanced GG
stuff
because some people want to watch the
word bro no I don't want to watch the
world burn
yeah I'm probably not gonna be able to
hit that yet dude
I wonder how long if I remember
correctly you have to
hit the Fire part down on this but you
have to get it up there first
let's get a another stick we probably
need one
let's push this down
[Music]
this is the N64 version I wish they
would have gave you a different one
playing this game and all yeah I'm
playing in the online thing
people kept telling me I should have
emulated it for like better performance
and stuff and they ain't wrong but
I don't
know just doesn't sit right with me
nothing against it just doesn't sit
right
I think it's two three one
two
three
one
yeah that's that's what it was
how did you know our secret how
irritating it's so annoying that I'm
going to reveal the secret of the queen
Goldwater to you in order to administer
the kupata grace to strike with your
sword while she's stunned oh and Queenie
sorry about that
[Music]
first boss
um I do use walkthroughs but
my walkthroughs are a little bit
different like I use walkthroughs
generally when I'm like want
a certain like a playthrough on like a
Dark Souls game and I want like the best
weapon I can use for a certain thing I
will use a walkthrough for something
like that
you gotta hit him with that jump one man
thank you
[Music]
oh get him get him get him get him get
him
oh my God
what's my favorite boss fight in the
game
[Music]
there's a lot of different boss fights I
enjoy
[Music]
man
okay
I'm at the fighting this time
[Music]
he's gonna try to follow me now
I have to get these hits right around
but to lose
[Music]
oh
I was letting him get too many hits on
learning this switch control is
difficult
[Music]
how I didn't get hit
I'm very curious how he hit me
I feel like you guys saw that
was
[Music]
the question is is it worth going down
there for that
I need that fourth heart so it is to me
it's worth going down there
oh that's so irritating
foreign
it's not like it was far I didn't have
to go far for it but as far as my
favorite boss
I don't even know what would my favorite
balls be in Zelda in this game
particular
[Music]
I really like the
the fire boss I felt like he was well
done
[Music]
there's a there's a couple different
bosses that I feel it's done pretty
decently
thank you
how long did it take to be one boss
we've been streaming for 44 minutes
take about 30 40 minutes to beat every
boss
a lot of bosses though my goal is to
beat the game to at least beat this
portion
by the end of the day
the when you're a kid
that's my goal
but I gotta sneak into Zelda's thing I
gotta do that there's a lot of things I
gotta do
I wish you could skip these
they're really bad at letting you skip
these though
yeah um you got to consider too uh I did
blow it Up Normally it look it's like
it looks weird
but I feel like I feel like you guys
would want to see the actual screen
it kind of stretched it a little bit but
I think it looks fine
let me look
let me look at the stream real quick
yeah it stretched it a little bit
all right so I do see the Stream
needs to be shortened a little bit
[Music]
wow is that that's not me
that's just a game
hold up
does that really how the game looks
leave it to Nintendo not to do anything
extra with these things
we get it you need all three of them to
make Triforce
[Music]
oh they they use some of the black
some of that
[Music]
foreign
it would take me a little bit longer to
beat maduro's mask because I don't
remember much of anything about maduro's
mask
[Music]
and think about like there's no voice
acting back then like
if you think this game holds up so well
[Music]
notice that they never did fairies again
like ever again
like did they did maduro's Mass which is
those are twin fairies
then Wind Waker was the The King
he was up
Twilight Princess was the queen of the
Twilight Princess uh or whatever you
named her I can't remember
Skyward Sword
[Music]
I can't remember Scott Russell
I just beat scarator not too long ago
too
it might still be downloaded
no it's not
okay
[Music]
oh
all right so now I think I I need to
stretch it
[Music]
it's a little bit more realistic now
it's showing that top part
[Music]
all right so now let's stretch it a
little bit there we go
[Music]
this is Sarah
she gives you the Ocarina
it's not the same Ocarina you get from
Zelda though
it's a different colored Ocarina
[Music]
I feel like
I really do feel like they they need to
just do better when it comes to
the extra work that they want they want
my money but they don't want extra work
in terms of putting stuff in here I
think that's the biggest issue like if
you want my money
give me extra work that's all I'm asking
for
then again I gave them my money I
subscribed so maybe they don't need to
do anything
[Music]
come on
I know I get very impatient
I'm a very impatient dude very impatient
[Music]
come on
extra work for which game for Majora's
man I mean one way uh Ocarina of Time
like at least make the game full screen
like at least do that much Nintendo
we really let you slide off a lot of
stuff at least make it full screen I
shouldn't have to make the green the
game full screen on my end which looks
really weird
on screen just to to give you guys a
similar what decent experience
that Al's gonna talk to me yeah
that's fine though
I remember you being able to skip
conversations by holding like the x
button or something
[Music]
yes I got all that
yes
thank you
taking forever
forever
[Music]
all right here we go
Zelda full screen looks weird
oh
[Music]
we're gonna get stuck We're not gonna
make it
go go go go go go go
almost there
are you serious
they need to do something
I remember these things spawning quicker
than that spawning
Nintendo
man and the sad part is they got IPS
that are so
they got IPS that are so memorable and
so nostalgic to us that like we just
have to deal with it
he's just not gonna play the games
[Music]
I can't believe I missed that by a hair
by literally a hair
I felt like if I would have rode for
those extra couple rows I could have
made that
now we gotta sit around here for like
a couple minutes
look how quick the day and light cycle
are on Zelda
not too bad
[Music]
is this the news outer game it looks
great
imagine if they remade Zelda fully from
the ground up
I think people would lose their mind
[Music]
I think you got to come here at night
to get the
I don't know I can't remember
[Music]
I think you have to come back here at
night get that chicken to wake up her
dad
[Music]
it's best I'll wait here and go in right
when it turns dark
oh
dude if you think about it like really
think about Zelda was so far ahead of
its time had a day night cycle
it had things like
this gate shutting if it got too if it
got night different enemies show up
during the day and night
stealth mechanics
I don't think this game gets enough
credit for how Innovative it was
then again people consider it one of the
best games ever made so it probably does
get that credit
[Music]
s
oh my God One's Gonna turn dark
I'm not trying to sneak over there
I guess I could have went on the other
side
[Music]
am I too close to the castle
it happens like really fast
it's like light than the dark
[Music]
and then you gotta think like the
perspective of Zelda coming in from like
a seven year Gap in the world's
different like games today don't do that
like just think about it like Final
Fantasy
uh yes we will be talking about Mario
uh tomorrow during r r
[Music]
ow come on
close the door
there we go
now she should give me what I need
before
okay maybe I have to to go to the castle
first
oh Final Fantasy
15 had like a into the Future Part and
it didn't do nothing
that this game did and if you think like
the amount of potential that Final
Fantasy had imagine if like half the
game was in the past that half the game
was in the future
I feel like people would have
[Music]
I feel like people would have gave it
more of a benefit of the doubt
[Music]
all right
there's like a certain way you got to do
this without being seen
it
looks like it worked fine the first
attempt unless I get seen now
that'd be unfortunate
I think you might have to see the
sleeping
dad first
look at all this money I'm getting just
for swimming imagine if you could just
swim and get money
let's go
all right so I think we have to get
intentionally seen now
kicked me out
I know you could pay the the Hyrule Dude
too
he'll do it for you
[Music]
all right he might give it to you now
she might give it to you now
[Music]
there we go
oh yeah it's an egg right now
[Music]
oh let me put a
let me record gameplay
all right so first off let's
because you could pay the guard he'll
actually open the gate for you but to me
it was a waste of money because if you
get caught one time when you came to
open up that gate you just have to pay
him again it might stay open
but to me it's like jump over
[Music]
it's not like you get damaged or
anything and as long as you do this part
right
and don't do that should have went up a
little bit more
doesn't really matter though because
[Music]
it's easy for me to get right back there
all right let's try going a little bit
more over
maybe it's because I did it in the dark
so it was easier there you don't see me
[Music]
that egg got a hat stuff
thank you
[Music]
I think it might take a whole cycle a
whole day cycle to do it
hottest
I don't know man I
hate that game is getting is ridiculous
for no reason
is this damn egg gonna hatch
oh
maybe it takes a whole day for it to
hatch I don't know
gatekeeping me man gatekeeping me
come on
let me move my camera over just a little
bit
trying to use this backrest a little bit
more
so apparently we gotta wait for this
stupid ass egg to hatch
whenever it decides to hatch it'll
probably hatch in the morning
yeah there it goes
foreign
there we go
I love how the the egg hatches and from
the The Roosters going and it also
hatches so why did he wake up from the
original roosters going off it makes no
sense
[Music]
yeah yeah
that's what would happen these days
you're right
why can't I move that
[Music]
there we go you have to actually
physically grab it
[Music]
foreign
I wish we had access to Twilight
Princess
Zelda taking forever to do anything
well Wind Waker what are we playing you
know what we playing it's in the title
akw it's in the title stop acting like
you don't know what we playing
[Music]
now we gotta crawl into Hyrule Castle
these can get a little complicated
[Music]
I mean we we might
we might be seen here I don't know
we're about to find out though
does he look backwards I don't think he
looks backwards so we're good there
[Music]
most of the time you're fine if you
climb this but I'm horrible at climbing
this
one of these is like really really fast
we just stay behind this dude
I think we'll be fine as long as we stay
behind them
[Music]
keep looking left and right man
there we go
[Music]
I think this is the last one
I think there's two people I think
there's one yeah there's one right there
[Music]
think we'll be fine though as long as we
stick it as long as we stick good
we good
[Music]
all right if I remember correctly
there's actually an Easter egg
one of these will throw a bomb at you
and you have to pick it up
and throw it in the other one
you might only have one at this
it looks like you only have one attempt
[Music]
Princess Zelda
what's up Mark
playing the old zeldas man you know how
it is
[Music]
I think I so I have one I need the one
in the fire and I need the one
and um Zero's domain Zorro's domain so
those shouldn't be too complicated
[Music]
this is a good game man it's good
I am Zelda princess is a high roll
what is your name
addict
strange it sounds somehow familiar okay
then addict I'm going to tell you the
secret of the Sacred realm that has been
passed down by the royal family of
Hyrule please keep this a secret
I'm gonna tell them no we don't keep
secrets around here
don't be a blabbermouth
please keep it a secret no
come on oh so you you have to
not keeping the secret just so I don't
have to see a stupid
cut scene
[Music]
the three goddesses hid the Triforce
containing the power of the god
somewhere in Hyrule
the power to Grant the wish of the one
who holds the Triforce in his hands
we might have to like
react to the timeline stories of Zelda
in general it's it's a really serious
thing man I don't think you guys realize
how in depth
Zelda's timelines are
it's a very in-depth thing there's like
three different timelines there's a and
what's funny is like they all Branch out
from this one Ocarina of Time is like
the catalyst
bring these gameplay streams to Twitch
I don't know
we should be streaming on Twitch we
might not be I don't know
Zelda says stop snitching
it's a good game man I really enjoyed it
yes I understand
[Music]
don't you love how there's a a window
conveniently looking into this room
uh go ahead and look through
this game wants to give you the illusion
that there's options but there really
isn't
you know gandorf's
Phantom in the Forest Temple was pretty
cool I like that one ganon's Phantom do
you guys remember that when you fought
gannon's fan uh ganon's Phantom in that
room he came out of like the mere uh the
the pictures
that's like the first dude you fight as
an adult in this game
[Music]
let's go what's good 108
please okay acting like I lots of you
could say I don't know and it just ends
I'm on the knee I'm playing it on the
switch I don't know nothing about those
emulating things Mark and I'm not trying
to learn to be honest with you
I'm just trying to find these two
spiritual stones and calling today
[Music]
I wish they would have just gave us the
that version and just let us let us do
that Lord Metro with a two dollar Super
Truck addict playing greatness at work
just saying I appreciate the support man
definitely uh makes doing these streams
a little bit easier on my back my
backhand in the best condition these
days
[Music]
under streaming
but I don't know if
I'm from
yeah um is there any more peps left
[Music]
um
yeah yeah that's fine
oh we need Zelda that talked for the re
for the real shout to this it tried to
be amazing
oh yeah that's right hold up
appreciate this five dollar script shot
108. you know I love Zelda Zelda's
always been like one of the Catalyst to
gaming to me Zelda Final Fantasy you
know I I don't think I would be in
gaming without these games
what's mdk2
foreign
[Music]
thank you
oh that's cool
foreign
[Music]
just because I'm playing some of these
older games don't mean I'm willing to to
play some of these other older games
okay we have to be a little bit more
easy on me when it comes to these
see you man
look here here's my thing
here's my thing when it comes to like
playing retro games
the blood pressure for it anymore okay
sometimes I play stuff because you guys
will do like a you know you buy a
certain amount of merchandise
but I don't got the blood pressure
anymore I just don't
you know
got bad
genes in general all right
you know I got issues of my life too
[Music]
let's get in here man
this is addict he is under my orders to
save Hyrule imagine like kind of like
cryptic message that is this is addict
he is under my rule to save Hyrule
foreign
right now I'm playing Zelda though
you know
gotta get that Zelda going I don't
really care about a show to be honest
with you guys
I can beat this game without a shield
does not bother me
have you been to the Happy mash up I
remember there's a a little bit of a
questline for the masks in Zelda I can't
remember what you get for them but I
remember that being one of them
so there will be an addict show and an r
r this week uh we we have returned in
full force
[Music]
Death Mountain Trail
we ain't trying to fight none of that
we trying to go straight up to the top
of the mountain
[Music]
we ain't trying to deal with none of
that
that's for the fishes
gorons
oh
I can't believe he pushed me off
like I failed you guys man
I should know better
instead I'm getting pushed off Giant
mountain tops
I should be ashamed of myself
[Music]
all right where you go where you go oh
you're not going that way so I'm going
the other way
I'm pretty sure if I remember correctly
I gotta get the gauntlet
[Music]
I don't know the next game I'm gonna
it's neither Majora's Mask
or I'll find something to be able to
stream like uh Twilight Princess or
something
I feel like Twilight Princess don't get
enough
love I'm gonna be real with you guys
foreign
[Music]
the fire temp was behind this thing
I think you have to play Sarah's song to
[Music]
oh my God
I don't think this is gonna work I think
you have to play Sarah's song on them
[Music]
oh no
what the heck who are you when I heard
the song of the royal family expected
their messenger had arrived but you're
just a little kid
at the boss of the gorons really lost so
much status to be treated like this by
his sword brother the king now I'm
really angry get out of my face now are
you asking why I'm in such a bad mood
right now
ancient creatures have infested the
dominance Cavern we've had a poor
harvest of our special crop bomb flowers
in hunger because of the rock shortage
but this is a Goron problem we don't
need any help from strangers
all right
okay let's go to the Lost Woods
[Music]
first thing we got to do
if I remember correctly because we gotta
turn on
we gotta light these torches and get
things going
might be wrong but we're gonna try it
purple
thank you
we got one two more
there we go probably not gonna be able
to save that stick
I doubt it at this point
I saved it
now
what we do is we use the fire
to make a bomb
okay we can't get nothing there
oh
crap
all right let's get this one now
see I don't want to roll because in my
opinion rolling is always made
this
go quicker
come on I don't need that
yeah I feel like rolling's always made
the stick go out quicker if you're
rolling with it in your hand when you
have it on fire
and I and I'd like to keep them as long
as I can
forget it we get it
[Music]
not only hear none of that again
all right
all right so that's the shortcut to the
water play
[Music]
like you they make you pay one of these
dudes makes you pay
all right hold up
[Music]
you gotta listen to what makes the most
sense
[Music]
yeah the sacred metal
laughs
[Music]
these wolves is like a uh
kind of an adult enemy
but you can fight them as a kid
sometimes
thank you
[Music]
there we go
I hear you I hear you you don't have to
tell me twice
we don't have to kill any of these
people we just had to make it to the
other side
you might have to kill them or at least
put up the shield
while walking
[Music]
do you think you're gonna like redfall
I don't know
I'm very up in the air about redfall I'm
willing to give it a try
uh but as far as me liking it that's Up
For Debate right now
I do feel like
IGN should be ashamed of himself for
showing the game and that kind of light
because I I've seen the game you know
the Lords did go play it and I've seen a
lot of video editing when I was editing
for that video
so I know there's better
content that you could have put up to
show the game and what it really is and
to me I just feel like they kind of
failed that
it's just my opinion on the matter
though to be honest with you guys
[Music]
but I'm willing to give it a try
and I think people need to
to stop being so
[Music]
Ocarina of Time
way better than breath of the wild I'm
gonna be real with you
[Music]
my what's funny is hold up hey babe
I think my girl fell asleep
hold up
there we go
such that they it's not that they forgot
how to play games they just never played
that game
no that Island will not outshine
uh Dying Light too and I will not talk
anything else about that Island too
[Music]
if you guys don't get down what I'm if
you guys don't pick up what I'm putting
down that's just I'm sorry man
[Music]
but then you know I do want to point out
that
[Music]
just cause I personally don't feel like
the game is going to outshine Dying
Light doesn't mean it's going to be a
bad game I do think the game's actually
going to do well I just don't think it's
gonna to me it's I don't think it's as
good as as Dying Light
you know and that that's it just depends
on if they have a lot of like
[Music]
elevation stuff like that you know I
gotta see I gotta see more on the game
before I can really speak on it
[Music]
foreign
Skyward Sword is a very good uh Legend
of Zelda game
I just personally feel like they could
have done it better
um you know the motion control you can
clearly see the game was designed around
motion controls and I feel like that
held the game back away
[Music]
I doubt I'll be able to remember
all right so I'm trying to go back
without going to the beginning of the
lost world yeah there we go
one Waker is definitely one of the best
ones
would you guys be interested in me doing
like uh top five Zelda games of all time
I'm curious if you guys would be
interested
thank you
foreign
[Music]
he starts he starts getting down to this
song
[Music]
hit it
he gives you the bomb flowers
foreign
I really never played the Dying Light
games I started the first one but I felt
like it's a bunch of fetch Quest that's
fair I would say that's fair I liked
enjoyed the Dying Light games because I
like the movement I really love the
movement when it comes to Dying Light uh
Dead Island just doesn't look like it's
gonna have that movement
but there's a lot of what different ways
that that Island too can you know
separate themselves from Dying Light
without being Dying Light uh sure I will
be disappointed because some of the
movement of dying lights not there but
if they do other things to you know make
up for the fact then it could do well
[Music]
oh
I need a really message someone about uh
Jedi Survivor
we don't really have EA contacts like
that
[Music]
how old is the first uh Dead Island
maybe I run through the
um I think they've made they've like did
repatches and stuff for the first time
like I mean Dead Island
Jedi gonna be good and I need to contact
I need to find me an email for someone
at EA if there's any content creators in
the chat they got an email for EA you
know uh slide it to you
my girl over here looking really nice
today
where is
I'm looking for
you gotta land it in that thing
I'm gonna mess up like a bunch
I think it's best for me wait
until
I have the bombs to do that
what's up babe
and the dude that he was on his podcast
she says hi
um I got faith I know some people that
work
at um
at respawn so I I do see they got a lot
of good talent over there a lot of good
talent
[Music]
oh
and what did Stu say how is the first
Dead Island
you mean Jedi uh fall in order
is it like was it like the the way the
game played was there something that you
didn't like for that
respawn don't miss respawn you can argue
respawn to one of the best Studios out
right now
I would put them up with even like a
naughty dog or something because I feel
like there's a lot of aspects that
Naughty Dog messes up but there's not
really a lot of aspects that respawn
messes up
oh
yes
yeah the show is probably definitely not
making that out of this place
that's fine
wow
I Gotta Throw It
all right so we gotta put this over here
all right so those little things spawn
in this room
they're not too hard to
maneuver around
one of these is alive and one of them
isn't
all right
Paul still breaks my heart I get that I
do think they're gonna do something with
Titanfall eventually but right now with
all the IPS that they're currently
working on and the ones that EA wants to
work on I think it doesn't financially
make sense for them to make something
like Titanfall
I'm disappointed but I guess that's just
the realistic Matt uh approach of it
catching on fire they catch on fire
which I'm not like I wouldn't be
completely upset if my show went away
but
I think it's best right now we keep our
show as long as we possibly can
here's the first dual fight
[Music]
this is like one
one of the reasons I want to keep my
shield right now
is because it makes fighting these
things a little bit easier
[Music]
start running
tonight
these are me or you
've always got some parts on it
[Music]
so far so good
I think this gets the next Side open up
here
let's just drop this right here I don't
remember what this opens we'll just drop
it see what happens
a door
[Music]
I think this dude actually sells and
stuff
I don't even know what I bought from him
oh yeah this thing this dude will burn
myself
[Music]
I remember in maduro's mask there those
things are like traveling around
yeah we're not getting burned
we need our mask I mean our
s
[Music]
not too complicated yet
I was at three of them in here
[Music]
easy peasy
one
two
three
three is the magic number
everybody in the chat tell me how the
the uh the the chat sound like do
do am I over talking the stream or is
the game over talking me or is it pretty
balanced I need to to know that
now we gotta go to the second
man look how slow these things take
this
all right let's open this up first
that's good
no
[Music]
we don't need a doctor show
he should have gave me money though
why are we just letting people live
that's the question I got
this is the one where you have to put a
well-placed bomb in the middle
but we're gonna open this up see what's
there because I can't remember
thank you
this should help this I think it brings
the platform down here
foreign
we're about halfway through the dungeon
oh let's climb climb climb
oh God oh God
all right so this is where we're gonna
lose
our ship
unless I can do that again
all right we good we good
I'm trying not to lose my shield like
the whole time
[Music]
all right he's not real
there we go
[Music]
I like how you look at it because they
want to make sure you're looking at the
right thing
all right this thing is not getting us
oh you can't just remove your Shield
I bet you I can make it
come on come on
following me
oh
yes I'm aware that you should have told
me the last time
see you man
appreciate you coming through
laughs
you gotta hold this for a certain amount
of time
okay
ah
gotta get that right timing
unless it's gonna explode in your ass
[Music]
hey you have a good day bam
oh here's the second fight
[Music]
come over here
thank you
[Music]
that's the first time where you bought
these things
[Music]
it's hard
this dude shouldn't be as hard now
[Music]
thank you
how you guys like that man
[Music]
a lot farther than I remember
laughs
oh I'm at the
read that here in a second
got bonds but no bomb thing
[Music]
I gotta find
oh no I gotta go back
there we go
got the bomb
push B
itch
easy
see
I'm sorry breath of water has no
structured temples like this and that
that's the part that
that's the part that irritates me it
doesn't have stuff like this
all right
[Music]
I don't care if I lose this Shield but
still
it's not a big deal
I'd prefer not to lose it though
[Music]
thank you
this is a fairy in one of these
foreign
like I don't think I need full house to
beat him but I'd like to have full
health
I should be able to make it before they
start hitting me we'll see though
oh
he's gonna get me again
I got your ass this time
gotcha
that's all I mean man like you how you
gonna have Zelda without dungeon
foreign
these are bombs in case you need them I
think it's a whole set of them
but we already had bombs
or something I don't know I don't know
how you guys want me to pronouncing man
I should have hit him there
oh I didn't I forgot he goes around the
corner like that
[Music]
foreign
I see you
[Music]
messed up
the problem is is I'm having a hard time
adjusting
to the controls the first switch
[Music]
this is hidden right here
so don't hurt the I don't hold the right
bumper
[Music]
see if you do that you're hitting them
two times instead of once
thank you
I'm Gonna Roll again okay I'll roll with
you
[Music]
see once you once I learned
it's not that hard
these bosses realistically only take
especially if you need to jump again
up
here
I love the crystal that makes like this
blue crystal
[Music]
oh
trying to determine if it's worth going
and just making sure I get
because I'm hungry but at the same time
I want to finish the kids life I want to
finish
young Link and go into the adult next
time we stream
[Music]
plus I got some stuff I gotta do I'm
gonna go ahead and finish
the third one because it shouldn't take
long
takes a little bit of time to get to it
but I don't think it's going to take
long
[Music]
laughs
people
[Music]
oh craps
all right so we could do stuff in this
Village
but we ain't going to I'm gonna be right
with you
we going straight for the third place
[Music]
I feel like I might have to come back
here
because I don't have a bottle yet and I
know you need a bottle for the fish
[Music]
let me just go ahead and do that just to
make sure I don't have to come all the
way back
because I don't remember where the
bottles are in the game
[Music]
laughs
I think she's got nine no she got six
seven
I think there was already one in there
the good thing is it doesn't take long
to get these these these aren't really
that big of a deal
up
I remember one of the present A Boss
there's a chicken
y chicken
[Music]
let me go over here and grab one of
these that's over here because there's a
chicken on this side too but if I
remember correctly you you need
one of these to get over there
hold up
I do remember you can get over here
[Applause]
[Music]
there is a chicken over here
we just gotta get over there first
I told you
now you just stole the chicken
[Music]
I'm pretty sure you can go in there if
you want to but we ain't doing that
right now
we can do all that when we're an adult
thank you
[Music]
what's up man
yeah right fault man we're definitely
going to be covering redfall there's no
denying that we're going to be covering
red fox we might got a little bit of a
game might be showing up as a review
here soon too
[Applause]
we got plenty in store for you guys
[Music]
I think there's a chicken up here too
yeah
thank you
babe
what you want to do about food
how many blood
there's two
okay well um I probably got about 40
minutes left until uh
I finished this
[Music]
be careful
it's 2 45.
there's a chicken over here
but I don't know where
where this other chicken
they said there's two chickens left I
don't know where the second one is
maybe there's a chicken up there by the
windmill I can't remember what all of
them
foreign
actually I'm gonna try to get yeah
there's a chicken up here
I'm gonna try to get like a really good
gameplay going with red ball I'll solve
the Lords me Cox off King just playing
the co-op experience I think that would
be fun
it's gonna be a lot of editing for me
but I think it'll be a lot of fun
we got one more
you could have definitely found your own
chickens I'm just gonna say that
huh
yeah see I knew she gave us a bottle
and we're definitely gonna need that
bottle
[Applause]
[Music]
all right let's see here
let's go
I could go to the ranch too there's a
few things that I'm definitely missing
all right
there's stupid owl's about to get me
harder
[Music]
at least he does tell you he does try to
educate you a little bit
what's up
well I wasn't looking at it so it didn't
blow up that's crazy
that it sounds like an Angus you guys
are ridiculous
like I said though after I beat this
next Temple we're gonna call it a string
there we go
climbing
um
I need this
all right that's Upon a Song
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
cam
there we go I forgot it
what about just a random door opens
is that our link I'm definitely wink I'm
not Zelda
I see what you try to do there
didn't succeed though did you
[Music]
so far the connection's pretty good
though
the internet's better for streaming it
seems all right
[Music]
oh okay
um
I don't think I can play that game yet
I think you have to be an adult to uh
play this game
[Music]
one two three four five
laughs
oh get up get up
we don't got much time
two more two more
[Music]
one more
everyone I prefer news yeah it's but the
problem is is like what it irritates me
is Nintendo has access to that game but
they gave us this one
maybe it's not as easy to put something
like that on here because they got like
touch screen mechanics but the switch
has touch screen mechanics they
converted plenty of of 3D games over I
don't know they irritates me a lot
[Music]
he's supposed to go yeah he gives you a
scale
I need one to dive more
[Music]
you eventually get the gold stuff I
remember correctly
now you can dive more
you could get to the the the
light through this thing
[Music]
that's why like you could talk whatever
you want about Zelda itself Zelda was
doing
was doing um
Dark Souls entries long before anyone
else would do
we got to catch a fish
[Music]
okay I don't remember what you have to
do
wow
I don't I don't think you have to do
this but I don't remember what
thank you
I feel like you gotta feed him to give
him energy to move
[Music]
thank you
and I really can't remember what you do
to get this dude
[Music]
open up the
downstairs is probably what you have to
do
[Music]
one second guys I'll get to you guys in
a second I see people calling
[Music]
because I remember you come back here in
seven years and everything is like
thank you
I don't know if I'm gonna make it before
this thing Burns Out
[Music]
craps
yeah so
200 rupees I can't get that
[Music]
arrows no that's good now
uh let's see let's read some of this
chat
I feel like the heads of Nintendo are
scuffing themselves they really hate
backwards compatibility yeah I'd agree
Nintendo has been great with backwards
because I really kept the same media
format from generations to generation I
just feel like they need to improve
the game in general
[Music]
I feel like I got to play this song
Somewhere
oh
[Music]
foreign
and I really do not remember how to open
this
[Music]
now watch when they add the GameCube
version they're going to say it's a new
game pretty much
[Music]
oh no now I remember what you have to do
you have to get the um the bottle in
Hyrule Lake
yeah
there it is
[Music]
please
so give me another bottle yep I got two
bottles now
[Music]
all right so now we got what we need
because I remember he even tells you to
keep the bottle he's like yeah keep that
bottle
[Music]
cups
grab the wrong one It's gotta be the
letter
foreign
I think
that they did what they can and they you
know did a lot of thrives to make up for
the Playstation 3 but I am confident
they could
if they could redo the PlayStation 3
they definitely would
[Music]
thank you
I remember how long this takes
a week a week
we are getting close to the uh
the Xbox showing this year it's like
what two months away I'm excited
[Music]
oh
thank you
[Music]
and this is the third tip
foreign
[Music]
being an adult if we we kept it going
do you think Indiana Jones is an XBox
exclusive or do you think Bethesda
agreement with Disney or multiplayer I'm
I'm indifferent with that I honestly
have no idea
what's going on what's going on
[Music]
you gotta do these by yourself
carry this person all through this I
hate this Temple
I'd rather do the water temple twice
before I do this Temple once
gotta talk to her multiple times to make
her sit down
we want
you
[Music]
she just she's a zoron too that's the
crazy part she's a zoron and somehow she
can't swim
[Applause]
so I won't be streaming today
or I mean tomorrow or the next day
because we have um
the attic shows on one day and we have
and we have r r tonight
so we'll be doing none of that I got
some patreon stuff I got to do as well
and some shorts and stuff I gotta do all
that
thank you
foreign
was looking for a way to fight him
without a shoe
foreign
[Music]
cats
listen
yeah I got two people
[Music]
come on
thank you
I need one more
[Music]
foreign
already the boomerang guys we got us a
boomerang
[Music]
thank you
make the stuff harder because those
things are up there now
it's not too difficult though we still
good
let's say it's not too much harder once
you get the boomerang
just gotta bait him down
[Music]
oh
I can't remember what this is it's
either the uh the map or the compass
[Music]
foreign
yes I'm aware it's gone
[Music]
before
man I hate these things
[Music]
foreign
because we got the one on that side
[Music]
oh
now that should be that one in the
middle now
oh
my God
[Music]
thank you
I was concerned though for a second
we got through it though we got through
it
[Music]
hello
there we go
[Music]
I need the one that is right behind me
let me rewind My Stream actually and
just
find when I first go in that room
all right so the
it's on the far left of the room
[Music]
some health would be nice just just to
say
[Music]
I don't think I'm gonna be able to beat
this dude
[Music]
all right we gotta fight this dude now
the best way to fight him
Dooku nuts if I remember correctly now
we got a half a heart left
so
we might win we might not
[Music]
oh my God
then he eventually turn around
[Music]
oh
I don't want to die
[Music]
not being able to get hit one time was
rough
[Music]
the good thing is I should be able to go
straight into that room
I hope I don't have to do the whole
thing again
yeah I wish I could have did that part a
little bit cleaner
[Music]
thank you
see I knew if I could Stone lock him I I
would be fine but it was just done
locking him man
[Music]
oh
my God
after you actually get a couple of hits
off
I could use those hearts
we'll talk a little bit about the Xbox
thing after I finish the stream I don't
know we'll see
how much time I have left
[Music]
try and spend a little time with my girl
playing on the switch control is like
really complicated
this raises up if I remember correctly
no razors down has no explanation why it
raising down it just does
that you drop that
boomerang
foreign
[Music]
what's up
this thing is like a lightning jelly or
something like that I can't remember
exactly
[Music]
look at this dude this is gonna be a
problem
gotta break these little things first
it shouldn't be too hard
[Music]
come on
all right
these things I really took a hit
oh
that that actually took a lot more
damage than I thought it was going to
[Music]
thank you
oh
that was crazy
that was a good fight
[Music]
now you guys are in the talk about that
Xbox but I might talk about it I might
take a little bit of time to you know
really go over some of the stuff but you
know there's a lot of stuff going on
right now
so I might not have time to do it
[Music]
this is kind of weird right here
foreign
[Music]
Sapphire so I got all three
all three of them
and it took almost three hours
to get three of them
[Music]
now I gotta go all the way back to
Hyrule Castle
oh
[Music]
foreign
thank you
isn't that the song You're supposed to
play
[Music]
I don't really care I know there's like
those three things like the three sacred
arts or whatever they call them on here
that you can get but
right now that's not my like primary
goal
I do like the fire one fire one's pretty
nice
I wish they would bring that back in
like tears of the Kingdom just to have
that spell that would be cool to have
that spell
[Music]
yeah um I think BioWare you know we
don't know what Xbox would have done
back then if they should have bought
water wear
[Music]
like you know I think they're a
different company than they are now
they could have really messed things up
but considering what's happened to
BioWare maybe it was a better
alternative
[Music]
oh
yeah
I don't think there's actually a way out
of Hyrule Lake which I'll take a while
away
[Music]
pretty sure you could take this Lake all
the way to the entrance
uh obviously going to get hit a couple
times but you can do it
I don't get all this money that I can't
use
[Music]
foreign
with Zelda throwing the Ocarina the blue
Ocarina off the horse is about to happen
see you know something's different
because the gate uh the the castle gate
is is open is closed normally the castle
gate is open at this time but it's
closed right now
so something different about that but we
all know because this game's like 1998.
all right
foreign
[Music]
Gandalf is definitely one of the
one of the good ones one of the good
and tag this in game
[Music]
thank you
hey
[Music]
guys
we knew what was going to happen let's
be real here
[Music]
Ocarina of Time
I remember somehow she puts some Vision
in you like that makes a lot of sense
she's able to do some form of vision
[Music]
at least make it believable
foreign
[Music]
this is hard
so that's going to be difficult
[Music]
you've learned the song of time
what if you're gonna be still in the
water I can't remember if you are or not
nope they put you on there
foreign
[Music]
this particular one right here
me like has a lot more meaning to me
than just about anything else
[Music]
I'm gonna claim it for the day
we'll probably start again friday-ish
maybe I don't know we'll see
but what I think I will do is we will
back out to a just chatting scene real
quick
and we'll talk a little bit about the
Nintendo thing I mean the the Xbox thing
oh
I see you guys you guys got me
for five minutes
five minutes you we could talk about the
Xbox thing five minutes and then I'm out
I'm out in five minutes
you hear me five minutes
so what what what were you guys talking
about when I was playing Zelda because I
saw a bunch of PlayStation and Xbox
conversation what was you talking about
I'm gonna go get something real quick
foreign
all right uh do you want me to come down
there you or you by the time I'm done
is your car parked on the side oh yeah
it is okay I'll come down there with the
car
okay let's see here
what do you guys think is gonna happen
with the the Xbox E3 show this year
I think it's going to be big I think
it's going to be small
I can't show you guys's opinion on the
matter
yeah it seems to be two hours I'll
probably make a video on my personal
YouTube channel about the stuff uh but I
probably will be closing out the show I
thought I had a little bit more time but
the girl wants me to come down uh there
and I mean I don't wanna
this pointer but I'll talk see look here
here is my
Maya
that's my ringtone
all right but I'll talk to you guys
later you have a good stream and I'll
see you tomorrow at r r peace